Trascrizione: Alessio Politi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Avete prima imparato
a leggere o a parlare?
La domanda è retorica:
sicuramente, avrete prima
imparato a parlare.
Poi, con la scolarizzazione,
vi è stato insegnato
a leggere e a scrivere.
Quando i vostri maestri
vi hanno insegnato a leggere e scrivere,
sicuramente sono partiti da parole
di cui voi conoscevate il significato.
Non faccio scrivere a un bambino
una parola che non può comprendere.
Iniziò a insegnargli a leggere e scrivere
dalla parola "Ape", dalla parola "balena",
eccetera eccetera.
È scontato, quello che sto dicendo:
ma purtroppo, per qualche motivo,
nell'insegnamento della musica
questa accortezza
non ci è stata data spesso.
Cioè, vi hanno insegnato,
probabilmente a scuola -
con il flauto di plastica che molti di voi
ricorderanno come un incubo -
vi hanno insegnato partendo dalle note,
cioè dalla forma grafica di cose
di cui non avevate un'esperienza diretta.
Ti insegno come si scrive il Do:
ma tu non l'hai mai fatto,
non l'hai mai vissuto,
non sai che cos'è quel Do.
E allora, da qui viene
probabilmente, per molti di voi,
la frustrazione della musica a scuola.
E ci sarà stato qualche insegnante
che vi ha detto:
"Non siete portati per la musica".
A me è stato detto, più di una volta.
Non è così, vi hanno ingannato.
Soprattutto,
quell'insegnante che ve lo ha detto
non era portato per fare
l'insegnante di musica.
Probabilmente era
un grandissimo musicista,
io questo non lo so;
ma non sapeva insegnare la musica.
È passata tanta acqua sotto i ponti,
da quando questo signore
ha inventato una metodologia
per insegnare la musica ai bambini.
Karl Orff, compositore
dei famosi "Carmina Burana",
sostanzialmente ci dice che i bambini
amano giocare, e non amano studiare.
Quindi, se tu gli vuoi
insegnare qualche cosa,
devi fare in modo
di insegnargliela giocando.
E lui, chiaramente, parlava della musica;
ma in realtà questa cosa si può applicare
a tutte le conoscenze umane.
Dalla sua metodologia,
ne viene una classe
che è completamente diversa.
Nelle mie classi, nelle mie aule,
i ragazzi, i bambini
non hanno banco e non hanno sedia.
Quindi sono liberi nello spazio,
si possono muovere;
ma soprattutto,
si va a ribaltare quel teorema
per cui il Professore sta sulla cattedra
e tutti gli allievi sotto imparano.
Nelle mie aule si sta in cerchio,
e si condivide un'esperienza.
Un'esperienza che ha tantissime forme.
Perché la musica non -
non è solo suonare uno strumento:
musica è anche cantare, ballare,
oppure percuotere il corpo.
(Musica)
Questa era body percussion: io la utilizzo
nei miei laboratori a scuola.
Perché il corpo è la prima cosa
che l'essere umano abbia suonato.
Non ha costruito un violoncello,
il primo uomo sulla terra,
ma ha suonato il proprio corpo.
E il corpo lo hai sempre con te:
non costa nulla,
non lo dimentichi sull'autobus.
Quindi io, quando inizio a lavorare
con i bambini, inizio dal corpo.
Questo insegna, anche,
la coordinazione nei movimenti.
Importantissimo: la musica è un gioco.
E come tutti i giochi,
si fa insieme agli altri.
Avete l'idea del pianista
che impara da solo,
nella sua stanza,
con un mozzicone di candela,
e passa le sue giornate a fare scale?
Ecco: quel sistema lì
magari formerà qualche bravo musicista,
ma ne annienterà tantissimi.
Se io faccio giocare i bambini,
li faccio giocare insieme;
e insieme condividiamo
un'esperienza di gioco musicale.
Questo azzera la frustrazione,
e gli abbandoni.
Nei Conservatori, ci sono percentuali
di abbandono altissime.
Come imparo, allora?
Come faccio a fermare dei concetti?
I concetti si fermano,
nella mente dei bambini,
quando sono legati alle emozioni.
Sicuramente, tutti voi avrete in mente
una lezione di un vostro insegnante;
e se ve la ricordate,
è perché lui in qualche modo
è riuscito a farvi emozionare.
Con la musica si fa presto,
perché la musica veicola le emozioni.
Allora io uso sempre musiche "importanti",
quando lavoro con i bambini.
Non uso le classiche musiche per bambini,
perché non ha senso,
la musica "per bambini":
la musica è musica.
Esiste musica di buona qualità
e musica magari con qualità inferiore;
ma la musica brutta la sentite
tutti i giorni, continuamente:
basta accendere la radio, la televisione,
un jingle pubblicitario.
La musica buona
è quella che ti fa emozionare,
e ha anche un linguaggio più complesso.
Se io insegno a un bambino
la musica, come un linguaggio,
gli devo fornire parole diverse.
Allora si usa il Jazz,
allora si usano i Pink Floyd,
allora si usa la musica
delle percussioni africane.
Una ricchezza culturale, musicale.
Questo trasmette le emozioni:
e come abbiamo detto,
se ti emozioni non te lo dimentichi più.
Sicuramente tutti voi
si ricorderanno dov'erano
la notte in cui l'Italia
ha vinto i mondiali a Berlino:
che cosa hanno fatto, con chi erano,
e forse anche che cosa hanno mangiato.
Perché quell'emozione, per voi,
rende quella giornata indelebile.
Bene: allora, se io costruisco
un tipo di classe
gestita in questo modo qua,
e chiedo ai ragazzi e ai bambini
di creare, di usare la loro creatività,
di emozionarsi,
allora poi non posso dirgli:
"quello che hai creato è sbagliato."
Nelle mie aule l'errore non esiste,
perché è attraverso gli errori
che si crea il programma e la creatività.
Io posso costruire qualcosa
sbagliando continuamente,
e aggiustando il tiro continuamente.
Se dico che l'errore non esiste,
elimino immediatamente la frustrazione.
Elimino quel "Non sei portato
per la musica".
Perché tutto quello che tu realizzi,
tutto quello che il bambino
riesce a inventare,
magari con dei piccoli
strumenti a percussione,
o col canto, o con il movimento del corpo,
è giusto, è la sua espressione.
Facendo questo,
nell'Aula si crea, indubbiamente,
una notevole inclusione.
Guardate: l'inclusione non serve solo
per allievi che hanno
determinate necessità.
L'inclusione serve a tutti,
perché magari un giorno
ci svegliamo tristi,
arriviamo a scuola,
e abbiamo bisogno di sentirci
abbracciati dagli altri,
di sentirci inclusi.
Questo vale per tutti.
A un certo punto ho pensato -
siccome avevo anche
degli allievi più grandi,
degli allievi adulti
che venivano ai miei corsi,
ho pensato:
ma se tutta questa cosa
funziona con i bambini,
allora forse funzionerà
anche con gli adulti.
Perché ci sono degli adulti
che vengono a suonare
nei miei corsi le percussioni,
che non hanno mai suonato in vita loro.
Magari il flauto alle medie.
Allora ho detto:
se funziona con i bambini,
deve poter funzionare con tutti.
E mi sono reso conto, nel tempo,
che senza se e senza ma -
visto che è il tema di oggi -
tutti, ma proprio tutti,
possono suonare uno strumento.
(Musica)
(Applausi)
Grazie!
Pedrasamba!
Potete venire tutti a suonare
con noi, se volete!
Pedrasamba, grazie.